it's a growing company one of the
fastest in its state one of the fastest
in the country but with most of the
production centered in China everything
it's zero shus has taken a hit because
of Donald Trump's trade war that's
pretty hold an investment and on hiring
we're confident that we can stay in
business we'll do we'll do okay but it's
definitely gonna affect how we do
business how profitably we are how fast
we can grow how much we can provide the
product that our customers want at the
price that they like it Donald Trump
imposed another round of tariffs on 300
billion dollars worth of Chinese goods
at the start of this month that adds to
the tariffs that were brought in last
year the President believes the deal
with China is close but he said that
before they had the worst year in over
50 you know they had a year there was a
disaster for them millions of jobs have
been lost their supply chain has been
destroyed or soon to be destroyed I
don't think they can continue onward
like that one California surf board
maker supports the president he's been
losing out to cheaper Chinese boards I'm
a proponent for as high as possible
because then it becomes competitive for
me the new jobs figure doesn't fully
measure the impact of the trade war but
it comes as an official report reveals
the u.s. created half a million fewer
jobs in the past 18 months and
previously reported Donald Trump sees
short-term pain for long-term gain
believing he's going to kick-start
American manufacturing unlikely say
steven sashen we would love to be able
to manufacture domestically but it's
literally not possible for us to make
our shoes domestically in the same way
that it's literally not possible
for to find a domestic version of the
devices you and I are using to speak our
computers in our cell phones the
infrastructure just doesn't exist to
allow us to back to America Donald Trump
says trade wars are quick and easy to
win he has to make that true if he wants
to take a strong economy into the 2020
presidential election Allen Fisher al
Jazeera Washington